[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Liberia la historia de este país
de África occidental es única en todo el
continente en 2022 Liberia celebró El
bicentenario de su fundación la
responsable de su nacimiento es una
asociación estadounidense que financió
la compra de tierras y el asentamiento
de unos 30.000 esclavos liberados que
cruzaron el Atlántico para instalarse en
la costa occidental africana de hecho la
ciudad que fundaron Monrovia convertida
en la capital recibió su nombre en honor
al presidente estadounidense James
Monroe Liberia pasó a ser oficialmente
una República independiente en 1847 pero
los esclavos liberados se convirtieron
en los líderes del país y relegaron a
las poblaciones nativas en 1980 un
habitante nativo logró subir al poder
por primera vez pero lo hizo gracias a
un de estado durante los siguientes 20
años el país atravesó dos guerras
civiles devastadoras que dejaron más de
250.000 muertos los conflictos
finalizaron en 2003 pero a pesar de sus
riquezas naturales Liberia está entre
los 20 países menos desarrollados del
mundo actualmente muchos habitantes
locales consideran que doscientos años
después de su fundación la nación sigue
marcada por las heridas de Las Guerras
civiles y de los crímenes que quedaron
impunes Esta es la historia
[Música]
en el estadio Samuel do de Monrovia
llegó la hora de festejar
este año Liberia celebra los 200 años de
su declaración de Independencia
en un continente donde la mayoría de sus
vecinos africanos lo llevan más de 60 o
70 aniversarios
el tema de este Bicentenario es el gran
retorno de los afroamericanos a sus
tierras africanas un orgullo para el
presidente
hoy que emprendemos un viaje por los
próximos 200 años pensemos Más allá de
este Bicentenario en la generación que
seguirá después de nosotros Durante los
próximos años y también en las futuras
generaciones que todavía no han nacido
Cómo podemos cimentar el camino para que
su futuro sea mejor que el nuestro sus
oportunidades más grandes que las
nuestras su crecimiento y su desarrollo
mejores que los nuestros
[Aplausos]
si hoy Liberia celebra su Bicentenario
es porque la historia de este pequeño
país de África occidental es inusual en
1822 el país recibió a los esclavos
libres y a sus descendientes que venían
de Estados Unidos
fue aquí en Providence Island donde
atracaron los barcos
en esta pequeña Isla una nueva vida le
esperaba a esos hombres mujeres y niños
libres lejos de la esclavitud que
conocían
el país fue incluso rebautizado y
llamado Liberia o la tierra de la
libertad
Elizabeth desciende de esas generaciones
Aunque vive en Estados Unidos en esta
fecha de aniversario decidió volver
sobre los pasos de sus ancestros
hace al menos 30 años que no venía aquí
su bisabuelo fue uno de los miles de
libertos que llegaron a Providence
Island
[Música]
me puedo imaginar lo que debieron sentir
mucha emoción pero el trasfondo era la
esperanza de libertad
el poder tomar decisiones sobre su
propia vida
Elizabeth hace parte de los hijos que
nacieron de la unión entre un americano
liberiano y una mujer nativa del país
para Esta generación de adultos educar
el pasado de sus ancestros es recordar
el doloroso periodo de la esclavitud
para la gente todavía resulta difícil
hablar sobre eso saben Hay un
sentimiento de vergüenza
un sentimiento de sí vergüenza
porque fueron esclavizados se
convirtieron en un objeto y no los
consideraron como humanos
no todos los esclavos liberados se
subieron por voluntad propia a esos
barcos
algunos fueron expulsados a la fuerza
por la sociedad americana de
colonización
una parte de esa asociación de
estadounidenses blancos estaba a favor
de La abolición de la esclavitud
y otra en contra de la idea de convivir
con esclavizados liberados
fundaron Liberia siguiendo el único
modelo que conocían el estadounidense
lo primero que replicaron fueron las
iglesias uno de los recién llegados
fundó la Providencia una iglesia en la
que el reverendo dix oficial desde hace
varios años
[Aplausos]
él quería estar con personas que se le
parecieran físicamente
que tuvieran el mismo color de piel
quería difundir el evangelio quería
difundir el cristianismo entre la
población
les da por eso se fundó Liberia para
traer la civilización para traer el
cristianismo a esta parte del mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la religión fue el pilar central de la
fundación de Liberia y también de la
vida política
en esta misma iglesia se firmó la
declaración de independencia de 1847
convirtiendo a Liberia en el primer país
emancipado del continente africano para
el reverendo dix este evento central
marcó el comienzo de la dominación de
los américanos sobre las poblaciones
cuando llegaron se encontraron con la
población autóctona con africanos
fue extremadamente difícil para ellos
crear vínculos de manera natural
optaron por las armas para que los
autóctonos les cedieran sus tierras y se
sometieran a ellos
los americoliberianos también llamados
congos ascendieron hasta la cima de la
escala social con su partido político el
party dirigieron el país durante más de
un siglo este edificio que se alza sobre
la capital era su sede principal
actualmente solo quedan ruinas símbolo
de una época que quedó atrás
este edificio ocupaba un lugar muy
importante
aquí se decidía todo en el pasado
antiguo periodista que ahora trabaja
como activista es importante deconstruir
los mitos que envuelven los inicios de
la historia de Liberia
se dice que Liberia no fue colonizada
pero eso no es verdad
fue colonizada pero por una organización
no gubernamental que asumió el control
la población autóctona fue dejada de
lado y mantuvo Ese odio y esa rabia que
terminaron por manifestarse en los años
[Música]
como lo demuestra la destitución del
último presidente Américo liberiano en
el año 1980 fue un momento decisivo en
la historia de Liberia Samuel domó el
control por la fuerza y se convirtió en
el primer presidente autóctono del país
fue la revancha de los nativos sobre los
combos de su gobierno También estuvo
marcado por la violencia y la corrupción
10 años después Charles Américo
liberiano por parte de su padre y nativo
por parte de su madre invadió el país
desde Costa de Marfil y destituyó a
Samuel
Ese fue el comienzo de la guerra civil
en Liberia que dejó más de 250.000
Muertos entre 1989 y 2003
[Música]
convirtió la búsqueda de los criminales
de guerra en su profesión
fundó la asociación de investigación y
Justicia global a través de la que
documentan las diferentes masacres que
han marcado la historia del país
hemos registrado entre 500 y 600
expedientes actualmente estamos
trabajando en varios casos
presidente de las asociación de víctimas
de masacres en Liberia y John Steward ex
comisionario de la comisión de verdad y
Reconciliación luchan por ponerle fin a
la impunidad porque hasta ahora ningún
criminal de guerra ha sido juzgado por
la justicia liberiana
el iberia la impunidad ocupa un lugar
importante
corrupción
Y por supuesto que la corrupción con
total impunidad va acompañada de abusos
de los Derechos Humanos
todo eso resultado no solo de la guerra
sino también de las desigualdades
sociales
que generaron tensiones desde que se
fundó la República
cuando un grupo de ciudadanos excluyó al
resto
este país nos pertenece a todos
necesitamos que se haga justicia no pasa
un solo día sin que las víctimas exijan
justicia si la justicia existiera en
este país en Liberia no habría
corrupción las personas hacen lo que
quieren y se salen con la suya
precisamente porque no hay justicia
lucha en particular por los
sobrevivientes de la masacre que ocurrió
en la iglesia San Peter de Monrovia
una iglesia luterana situada en la vía
principal de Monrovia
aquí ocurrió uno de los peores ataques
de la guerra civil una Modesta placa
conmemora los 600 muertos todos miembros
de las etnias mano y
guido algunos están enterrados debajo de
esta cancha de baloncesto
durante la noche del 29 de julio de 1990
unos soldados de las fuerzas armadas de
Liberia abrieron fuego sobre las
familias que habían ido a refugiarse en
la iglesia
años después los vitrales todavía se
pueden ver los impactos de las balas la
iglesia volvió a abrir sus puertas pero
algunos sobrevivientes nunca podrán
volver a rezar en estas bancas
recluidos en pueblos de difícil acceso
hay algunos que no pueden caminar ni
trabajar
este hombre de 50 años sobrevivió al
ataque en la iglesia San Peter fingiendo
que estaba muerto
estuve en la iglesia luterana con mi
hijo pequeño casi durante una semana
entraron sin decirle nada a nadie
empezaron a disparar recibí un tiro
justo aquí
al suelo las personas trataban de huir
entre los disparos y caían una por una
una sobre otra
el ataque le dejó secuelas físicas pero
también psicológicas rufus carga con la
pérdida de su hijo de dos años y de su
hermana que murieron esa lucha
hasta tiene
después de haber matado a todo el mundo
en la iglesia algunos fueron a la parte
de arriba para matar mujeres y niños mi
hijo el niño pequeño del que les hablé
estaba con mi hermana en la planta
superior algunas personas murieron
tratando de escapar por las ventanas
dispararon hasta asegurarse de que todo
el mundo estuviera muerto
unos traumas con los que rufus debe
vivir todos los días
[Música]
olvidadas por el gobierno muchas
víctimas dependen de activistas como
Peter
superarse y sobrevivir
[Música]
era Inevitable esta tragedia en un país
construido a partir de divisiones para
muchos historiadores Las Guerras civiles
fueron consecuencia de las tensiones
entre nativos y cocos
Pero según el activista que milita por
las víctimas esa suposiciones ya no
existe
cuando los afroamericanos llegaron a
instalarse en Liberia se podía
distinguir entre congos y nativos
dirigían el país y lo controlaban todo
pero ahora las cosas han cambiado si uno
se fija en la sociedad actual
es imposible diferenciar a los congos de
los nativos todo el mundo se parece
las desigualdades sociales del pasado
dieron paso a una sociedad consumida por
la corrupción la violencia y la pobreza
extrema
iberia es uno de los 10 países más
pobres del mundo
[Música]
una trayectoria que resulta sorprendente
para una nación que hace 200 años era un
modelo de democracia y desarrollo en
África
[Música]
ahora los jóvenes se reúnen en torno al
monumento
primer presidente de la nación símbolo
de paz y Reconciliación Para rezar por
su país con la esperanza de que Liberia
recupere su dignidad y su grandeza
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Liberia
visitamos el país para su Bicentenario y
recordamos la compleja historia que aún
afecta a la población local recuerde que
puede Ingresar a nuestra página web
France 24.com para ver esta emisión y
las anteriores Hasta pronto